[Music]
on this saturday night
remembering a real life superhero
the world pays tribute to trailblazing
movie star chadwick boseman
could be depicted as a superhero in film
and a superhero in real life rallies
across the country
renew calls to defund the police
the u.s president promises help for
hurricane-hammered states
as residents turn to the colossal
cleanup
plus a super discovery that's very rare
this canadian comic book collection is
in a class
of its own
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us
reaction is pouring in from around the
world to the heartbreaking news out of
hollywood
chadwick boseman the american actor who
broke new ground with the blockbuster
film black panther has had his
remarkable career cut
short bozeman's family revealed last
night that the 43 year old died
after a secret battle with colon cancer
the news shocked the film industry
and the legions of young fans now
mourning a movie star who devoted his
career to breaking down
racial barriers most
knew him best as the king of wakanda
[Music]
chadwick boseman's starring role in the
2018 marvel movie black panther which
raked in more than a billion dollars and
received an oscar nomination for best
picture
it was also the first major black
superhero movie
it's not just a movie it's become its
own thing it's a movement
people are excited about the cultural
aspect of it people are excited about
seeing something new
he put himself on a different level this
toronto community worker was part of a
fundraising campaign that paid for
hundreds of black canadian youth to see
the movie in theaters
the black panther movie showcased more
than just
a portrayal of black superheroes
it was showing us a world where
technology was guided by black thought
black creativity and and exclusively
black people
and that was a very positive image to
showcase to you
give me a number on my back i'll give
you the gut
boseman promoted that positive image
playing black pioneers such as jackie
robinson who broke baseball's color
barrier
man is an attorney you will treat him
with the respect that he deserves
and thurgood marshall the first
african-american justice to serve on the
supreme court
he actually was culturally aware of the
roles he was taking on
positive roles that was going to make an
impact on so many
and his superhuman spirit was also
deployed through his charitable work
he recently announced a four million
dollar donation for hospitals fighting
the pandemic
in african-american communities the
african-american community
has been hit the hardest and he spent
time visiting his youngest
fans in hospital including some with
terminal cancer
who were hoping they'd get to see his
movie
yeah it's it means a lot what his fans
didn't know was that bozeman was quietly
fighting his own battle
diagnosed with colon cancer in 2016 on
friday
it claimed his life news of his death
sparked an international outpouring of
grief and tributes
barack obama recalled their meeting in
2016
saying bozeman used his power to give
kids heroes
to look up to could be depicted as a
superhero
in film and a superhero in real life
chadwick boseman was 43
as well as the loss of actor chadwick
boseman a close friend
of the nba who appeared in iconic movies
and the nba held a moment of silence for
chadwick boseman as the playoffs resumed
in the wake of the police shooting of
jacob blake
players with the orlando magic and
milwaukee bucks blake's home team
took a knee wearing shirts with the
slogan black lives matter during the u.s
national anthem in an earlier statement
nba commissioner adam silver said the
league will immediately establish a
social justice coalition
increasing access to voting promoting
civic engagement
and advocating for meaningful police and
criminal justice reform
the raptors return to the court tomorrow
but no nba
games are scheduled beyond sunday at
this point meanwhile the vancouver
canucks are back on the ice tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
meanwhile family members of jacob blake
are leading a march today
calling for an end to police violence
protesters have marched on kenosha
streets every night since blake was shot
in the back
seven times by a police officer last
sunday he's now paralyzed from the waist
down and rallies were also held in
cities across
canada calling on their local officials
to defund police and invest
in social services morgan campbell has
more on whether those calls
are being answered those people are with
us
and we're with them an example of
strength in numbers across canada
people gathering with a common purpose
to invoke
change it's her warming to see that
there's more people
who there's other people who actually
care the coalition for bipoc liberation
held a nationwide day of action
in several cities saturday including
toronto montreal
moncton and calgary calling for
municipalities and regions
to cut their police budgets by at least
half
and reinvest that money in social
services
and communities it's actually not such a
radical extremist idea
it's actually something that's been
happening for years to approach things
with kindness and compassion
and give people access to resources to
rehabilitate themselves the movement has
gained
momentum over recent months following
the death of george floyd
during an altercation with minneapolis
police
and several other high profile cases in
canada
we are confronting structural changes
these are questions of how we lead
police
how we manage police how we govern
police
the transparency of police a
long-awaited bill that would see
oversight amongst the
rcmp and the canadian border services
agency
has failed to clear the senate twice in
edmonton the police budget has been cut
by
11 million with funds redirected to
social services and housing toronto
voted against a 10
percent cut to its police budget however
its force recently adopted the use of
body cameras
a measure which critics say isn't
necessarily
a step in the right direction it puts
the attention on the individual
sworn members instead of asking the
broader structural problems
that i think ultimately the defund
movement
is trying to lay there activists say
much of the concern
also involves the issue of systemic
racism
and current measures aren't evolving
fast enough
it takes a lot out of you and it takes a
lot for you to do your natural everyday
stuff
with this stuff in the back of your mind
morgan campbell global news
and as the rally in montreal was
wrapping up protesters toppled the
statue of
john a macdonald canada's first prime
minister that statue has been
the frequent target of vandalism in
recent years with protesters citing
mcdonald's treatment of indigenous
people
and politicians across canada are facing
pressure to address systemic racism that
includes recently elected conservative
leader aaron o'toole
he sat down with our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson to discuss his views
tomorrow on the west block we sit down
with new conservative leader aaron
o'toole for his exclusive first
television interview
with the west block on global news one
of the biggest stories this summer have
been
the black lives matter marches and
protests
as the nation struggles with issues of
systemic racism and equality
and what to do about it we asked the man
who would like to be prime minister
what his views are on whether or not
systemic racism
exists in canadian government
institutions and in the rcmp
here's what he told me i'm always going
to say i think there is racism
and i want to stamp it out but i i wore
a uniform i fight for people that wear a
uniform and when you use a term like
systemic
some of those people feel that you're
calling them racist
so can we improve community-based
policing can we improve
training can we make sure that
communities that are losing
faith in in the public services or the
rcmp
can have that faith restored i'd invite
you what is the definition of systemic
racism
there is no definition it's tossed
around with the concerns about
anti-black racism in the united states
and right here in canada
this is not an issue that will go away
for any canadian leader
and for a conservative leader who says
that he wants to have a big tent and
canadians of all backgrounds and
identities feeling comfortable
it is something the canadian politicians
will have to seriously address
mercedes stevenson global news toronto
protesters also took to the streets of
ottawa and several european capitals
today
rallying against public health measures
meant to stem the spread of covid19
as david aiken reports these protests
come as canada and some european
countries
are watching their covet 19 cases
climbing
on parliament hill a few hundred
protesters gathered amid some gray
drizzle
there were trump supporters for example
quebec nationals
but also a strong presence of those
bearing the symbols of
cuanong that's a baseless conspiracy
theory that among other things
believes that the world's elites are
operating a global pedophile ring
and that only donald trump can do
anything about it but whether it's q
anon or others in this crowd
they are united by a distrust of the
government
the police and the media and the belief
that
scientists are not telling the truth so
we're going to want to talk about
everything from satanism you name it
pedophilia
mass mandates injections mandatory
vaccinations
anything that people want to talk about
when it pertains to this latest
lockdown pandemic civil authorities in
canada and around the world are
grappling with strategies to deal with
these kind of protesters
in paris these protesters railed against
coven 19 restrictions
even though france hit a near record
high number of new cases
on friday and the fact that the united
kingdom
leads all of europe in coven 19 deaths
with more than
41 000 did not move this protester
the main reason why i'm here is that the
severity of covid
has been blown out of proportion so the
measures that are in place
are unnecessary and yet public health
officials around the world including
canada
unanimously recommend social distancing
and wearing a mask
to help stem the spread of the virus i
would advocate people to wear a mask
and it would be an added layer of
protection
the number of new canadian cases
reported every day has remained
relatively stable and relatively low
throughout most of the summer
but canada's public health agency
reported on saturday
that the average number of new cases
reported across the country in the last
week
ticked up to 425 cases a day
that's compared to 400 cases a day
in the previous week jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david the
american president touched down
in louisiana and texas today to see
firsthand the destruction left by
hurricane laura
at least 16 people are dead thousands of
homes and businesses have been destroyed
and as jennifer johnson reports trump is
now promising to help
residents rebuild aerial footage shows
what is left of cameron louisiana
after hurricane laura made landfall and
tore apart the small town
throughout parts of the state the
national guard is still extracting
citizens
left stranded by the powerful storm in
many areas there is no food
electricity or water and it could stay
that way for weeks it's a war zone it
really is
it looks like a tornado came through
more than a hurricane
u.s president donald trump spent
saturday viewing the devastation in both
louisiana and texas
pledging billions to help both states
recover the president started his tour
in one of the hardest hit areas
lake charles louisiana yesterday i
approved a major
disaster declaration that helps
individuals and business owners fema has
delivered 2.6 million
liters of water and 1.4 million meals
local officials say ongoing power
outages are threatening the health and
safety
of the sick and elderly that's causing
us to have a rolling series
of evacuations that we're having to do
from nursing homes
and from hospitals customs officers are
going door to door looking for survivors
for thousands of homeowners it's time to
get out the chainsaws and clean up
for others it's facing the reality that
everything is gone
it's sad it's sad
but we made it and me and my husband and
my two dogs we made it alive
fifteen years ago on this date hurricane
katrina the costliest storm in u.s
history
hit coastal louisiana the economic
impact of laura is not expected to reach
that level
but it will take months to get back to
normal jennifer johnson global news
washington coming up the pleas for
provincial help
as a heat wave hammers pei's potato
farms
welcome back farmers in prince edward
island are struggling to deal with more
than just the pandemic
severe drought conditions and record low
rainfall are devastating potato growers
as jesse thomas reports they're now
pleading with the province
for help potato farmers on prince edward
island grow on
average 2.5 billion pounds of potatoes
per year
this year their crops are in jeopardy as
most of the province struggles under
severe drought conditions
it's historically dry across the
province
to make matters worse godfrey says this
is the fourth straight summer where dry
conditions have hampered
the growing season cutting into farmers
yields and profits
i would say this is the worst the worst
year that we've seen actually
probably since 2001 following the 2001
drought pei
implemented a ban on drilling and use of
high capacity wells for irrigation use
on farms
godfrey says that needs to change he
says the ban is discriminatory and
harmful to farmers
you are able to get a high capacity well
for water access and you can irrigate if
you have a golf course for example
if you're building a car wash you can
get a high capacity well but if you
want to irrigate crops grow
food you can't greg donald with the pei
potato board agrees and says the
moratorium on agricultural irrigation
needs to be suspended
we're getting hotter higher temperatures
longer periods without rain
wind and it irrigation is another tool
that we need in addition to those
in nova scotia dry hot conditions are
making for a tough summer for many
farmers but there is one crop that's
thriving
grapes need about half the water than a
norm a lot of other crops need
so we're doing great it's looking like
it could be a great finish this year
there is one big challenge this year
though covet 19 has created a labor
shortage at vineyards across the region
come harvest time l's will be short for
temporary foreign workers
we have made it up with local workers
and they're doing a great job but we're
still just missing those experienced
professional hands
the pei federation of agriculture say
they met with premier dennis king last
week
and will meet again this week to examine
irrigation opportunities
in the meantime they'll hold out hope
for rain jesse thomas global news
sheffield mills nova scotia
still ahead why pandemic restrictions
are turning european travelers
topsy turvy
welcome back this summer most canadians
opted to vacation
at home or travel within the country but
canada
is very big of course similar in size to
all of europe which is home to more than
50 countries
and europeans are now struggling to
navigate a constantly changing landscape
of travel
restrictions redmond shannon reports
from london
[Music]
in normal times europe is a dream for
travellers
open borders cheap flights and fast
trains
but ever since the start of the covet 19
pandemic
the rules have changed in fact they've
never stopped changing
countries across europe are imposing
sudden mandatory self-isolation rules on
people traveling from
virus hotspots often with little notice
yeah rather rather be here in time than
have to quarantine for two weeks
on thursday germany asked its citizens
to stop traveling to at-risk
countries but what if you're already on
holiday
a lot can change during a two-week
vacation we asked before we
before we camped and it was a green zone
but no
it's a risk zone even britain's
transport secretary was forced to
isolate when the rules changed during
his vacation to spain
travelers are keeping a close eye on
this covid 19
case map yellow regions are generally
safe to return from
but coming from a brown area means you
might have to self-isolate
but each country has a different
threshold and the sudden rule changes
have caused
diplomatic tension we appeal to uk
government to replace this 14 days
quarantine measured by reliable tests
with so many people wary of travel
tourist meccas like venice
are almost empty we went into the doge's
palace
and we went into one of the main museums
to see a tintoretto
and i kid you not there must have been
12 people
instead of a thousand when i put my just
my tourist hat on it was amazing you
know it was like such a
wonderful experience just walking around
the city without massive crowds
but it's been devastating for the
tourism industry and for the foreseeable
future traveling abroad will be a role
of the dice
to say that this is frustrating and
confusing is to put it mildly
but if i was to be generous to the
health officials i would say is that
well i don't know what else
they can do having those rules is one
thing
abiding by them is another the eu's
trade commissioner was forced to resign
this week
after failing to self-isolate on a trip
home to ireland
redmond shannon global news london
up next why this canadian collection of
superhero stories
just received super rare status
[Music]
welcome back from billion dollar movies
to blockbuster conventions
comic books play a super-sized role in
our popular culture
and now a rare comic collection has
turned up in canada
jennifer palma explains three
absolutely incredible comics actually
only three of 1300 they're part of a
personal collection
dating back from the 1940s to the early
60s
that was my super bowl patrick chancy
owner of golden age collectibles says he
became aware of the rare comics in 1999
a man called him saying his in-laws died
and while cleaning their home he found a
huge stack of comics in the cupboard
he had no idea his father-in-law was an
avid collector and he used the comics as
a way to improve his
english skills he was a chinese
gentleman who worked for the cp ferries
he's i understand he was a cook and one
of the neat things about the collection
is
i found some photos at the vancouver
archives taken by jack lindsey
that show some of the newsstands where
he actually bought some of the comics
from
shaughnessy knew he was on to something
big and bought them
all for an undisclosed amount of money
not only were the comics in great
condition
some had unique markings on them both
handwritten and stamps
the coolest one is what i understand is
called a chop
and it's like a personal representation
symbol
so it's something that he would have
designed himself the comics have been
graded and deemed a pedigree meaning
they are very rare and valuable it's a
very famous cover
this edition of captain america stands
out it's been graded at an
8 out of 10 by the certified guaranty
company
so what's the value well the same comic
graded at 7.5
sold for 23 thousand dollars earlier
this year
a significant amount of the comics in
the collection dubbed chinatown
grade even higher so there's no telling
how much they're all worth oh that's
amazing i mean
that's very rare i mean to come across
something like that
pedigree right just the uniqueness of it
with the symbols
attached to it and just the story behind
it is really cool and yeah it's a great
thing to have
some are considered to be from the
golden age of comics that's something
not lost on shaun c for
now he's holding on to them you've got
to keep something you know when you get
a collection like this
jennifer palma global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm jeff semple tonight's your
canada is peggy's cove nova scotia to
share your canada with us email your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night
you